it's been 22 years since we started this
Saga how did we get so lucky to come so
far
this family is ready to come back
together it's a dream come true I mean
it's definitely bucket list for sure oh
we're at the Apex of his franchise fast
the heart and soul of The Fast and
Furious franchise boots on the ground on
location the more movies we make the
bigger they get we can you to outdo
ourselves because we owe it to our fans
the enormity of everything hits you like
a right hand of the jaw you still know
how to drive every time I'm on set I
have to pinch myself
I just have been badgering them to
participate in this it's such an honor
to be part of this family that's the
problem with having such a big family
how do you choose ones you saved we're
so lucky to be able to continue this
Saga for all of you